all right
Nathan welcome thank you Russell back
again
who wants to lead
Russell
um thanks Mr chairman I was going to
play wheels on the bus for the highlight
of the afternoon but I was just
discouraged by my colleagues here that I
didn't think that was a problem thank
you for the earworm it could do
excellent
so this afternoon we're going to run
through a person to transport and I've
brought Nathan girdle who you hopefully
will have known Nathan and I
um collectively manage our passenger
transport activity
um on the day-to-day Nathan looks after
the operational side of the world and he
coordinates with our contractor go bus
and does an awesome job making sure
those the buses continue to run out
there in the in the world
so just a little bit of statistics about
what we do and hopefully you've seen
some of this before a contractor is Go
Bus
and we have to tend to go to Tinder in
2024 her contract will expire
at the moment we have six spline based
routes for the city so that sort of
circulates in and out of the Hub and we
run between 720 and 520 Monday to Friday
and ten and three generally on Saturdays
Peak periods around 30 minute Peak kid
ways that means bus comes every 30
minutes so during those times we have
six buses on and the off-peak we have
three buses running
we have five school bus routes which
come across the city morning evening and
we run a service for the recycle South
two trips
put some numbers in there in terms of um
just the last couple days we've just
looked at the near end of June so we've
gone from a hundred thousand odd trips
and 22 to 125 which is I guess somewhat
more encouraging than um post covered
but um it's certainly down on where
we've been in the past but that's
actually
um less
depressing than we could otherwise have
seen it so we've gone from 93 so from 73
to 93 during our peak times
a few box has risen a little bit as well
so it's up as well in our current fear
which we enacted on the 1st of July has
gone in line with their fees and charges
to 2.20 for a b card and three dollars
cash
and the bottom line is probably the one
that um has just been happening as well
so obviously super gold is between nine
and three
um where you get free if you're over 65
with just with your suit with your
um super gold card but we also have the
community connect
um discount now so or to concession now
whereas if you have got a community
services card
you can go online it will come in and
you need a concession loaded on your
card and you get half price fears
if you are under 12 years old and you
have your
um correct age on your B card registered
you can travel for free and if you're
between 13 and 24 years old and you have
your age
on your B card and it's registered
um you can travel at half price so
that's the things that the government
have just put in place in those
concessions uh supported by the
government
any any service that
any
what's the right word services that we
run so all of our B all of our bus smart
buses and school bus
so hopefully we'll see more kids
traveling to and from school you know
but at the moment to be fair the fear's
been half price for the last
so and that's helped us a little bit but
technically if it hadn't otherwise it
was going to increase but what the key
message that we continue to want to be
out in the community is you've got to
get these concessions on your B card if
you don't you'll get the at worst the
2.20 if you turn up and you're an Under
12 year old and you're paying cash
you'll pay three bucks so there's a
learning cycle that they will have to
learn pretty quick
these are just a bit of a graphics about
what we're talking about on the left uh
the colored ones is how it all works so
they basically have
um use a common road on the way out so
that if you're traveling home you travel
and jump off if you're coming back in
you get another side of road and you
come back in and that's what the our
customers saw so therefore it reduces
your travel time
um unfortunately one of the downsides of
some of that is is that it actually
limits a little bit about the coverage
we have but in the design of it we
looked really close to you out where the
patronage was
and on the right hand side just as a
brief overview it's about I've taken
three of the five school bus routes and
just as an indicator of where the school
bus routes really do Meander through the
um
the the urban area to pick up kids and
drop them off at the high schools
predominantly on the way there so and
it's pretty well used at service it's um
the bus is a well patronized so it's
actually really really quite positive
the second part of what we also deliver
is our Total Mobility Services so Total
Mobility is a service that you're
assessed that you can't necessarily use
our other passengers transports by some
independent assessors and then you can
travel on a subsidized use of
small passenger service Vehicles I.E
what they used to be called as taxis
with a card and you get a concession
paid so we have seven operators in
invercargill who offer that service one
in Gore
and we have 10 hoist vehicles in
invercargill so if people with
disabilities and wheelchairs so they can
have a choice so there's I guess quite a
number
in 22 we had 2 000 registered users and
we've now got 2 302.
it's the number Nathan gave me just the
other day so I guess that's a good sign
lots of communities have lots of lots
more but that's actually people's
ability um that's their willingness to
be to assist and then join the scheme
and get this card so it's there for them
to use total trips um
59 022 and 82 2023 now part of that is
because the government
um during that time offered a further 25
subsidy incentive so at the moment
um it's generally 50 50 so if there's a
20 fear the um customer used to pay ten
dollars and then uh ten dollars would be
paid by Council and then nzta and us
would share that
um the government has of uh recent more
recent times said I guess it was when
the fuel and those sorts of things were
being subsidized that they would pay a
further 25 so the customer now only pays
25 of the cost
the impact of that unfortunately of
course fortunately unfortunately I guess
depends on
the budget manager you're looking at um
air trips have gone from 59 000 to 82
000 which is 140 rise which means our
budget spend
um
it's really Under Pressure including air
subsidy from wakutahi so that's costing
trips about another hundred three
hundred thousand dollars a year of which
we get back
um half of that so there's quite a lot
of pressure on our budgets in that area
um but I guess the the upside is is that
our community
um feels welcomed to be able to use the
service more frequently than otherwise
so
um the fear caps uh 50 so no one trip
can exceed fifty dollars for a trip so
that's what we place some trips are more
expensive if they go somewhere but we
keep it at fifty dollars so our input's
25.
just a little bit about our priorities
and how we um
respond to
um the approach and I guess what we need
to do is
we really that's just saying here a
response to our outcomes is really to
continue their current approach but
investigate some further delivery
options which we'll come to
and I guess the other big thing is
really us looking to
say who is the best person to deliver
these Regional services
just a little bit about their budget
like we've had seen before
um
Air Optics is about 2.8 million and we
get about 1.7 million dollars in terms
of Revenue back in so I guess the
pressures that we will continue to have
is our fearbox recovery is always a
ratio and that's a number that is always
interested in seeing and the fear boxes
how much we take from people paying
divided by the cost of the service
airfare boxes sort of in the
um around the low
20 percent and they're looking for it to
be much higher than that so I guess
that's an impact most Regional
regions have suffered post covert um
certainly the big centers have a much
better farebox recovery but
lots of their services are to reduce
congestion whereas as has a strong
Community element
because the thing that Nathan and I talk
quite a bit about is if you weren't able
to drive today how would you come to you
today what are your choices and and for
some people that is their only choices
to catch a bus
and I guess we've seen 125 000 trucks
because people have chosen or don't have
other options so it's quite a lot of
travel for people
to if you didn't have that service
so some of the things that we need to
look at
um
considering over the next two hour
activity plan our own bus announcements
and we have had some presentations to
council I guess that's how do we deliver
that and we still believe we need to
make sure that the solution is good for
all all users on the bus and we believe
an app-based solution has to be out
there so we've continued to work down
that rather than necessarily we've been
in the past which had a whole range of
positives but also some downsides where
we had to continue to maintain it and it
was quite expensive and and
hard to have on or off if you wanted it
we recognize that we've still got some
work to do on reviewing some of their
school bus routes it's been a long time
since we've looked at it but they are
pretty successful so not 100 sure we
need to change something that's not
broken but it's a good chance to have a
think about what it does do
on-demand services are things which uh
growing in a number of Trials across the
country
four or three
which is really a takes your service on
steroids I suppose is one way where you
actually dial up and they tell you where
to where to go to be picked up and it's
a piece of software that calculates
those but there are some ups and downs
of that but most people have layered it
over their existing service and then
decided which one's the better service
to deliver so there are some positives
and there are some disbenefits um bus
sizing is something that we will need to
look at about how big do our buses need
to be especially since
um we have to think about how do we
decarbonize buses and have e-buses not
allowed to have
diesel buses Beyond new buses brought on
to any subsidized service Beyond 2025 so
there's some real positives of that
but there's some real costs given that
an ebus is twice as expensive as a
normal bus
and given that you have to have the
infrastructure to charge them so that's
a piece of markete requirement through
the news
it used to be called the
pitom in which is the passenger
transport operating model but there's a
new piece they're working through
and the thing we need to continue to
keep a focus on is a declining person
numbers might have not you know it's how
do we actually keep them growing do we
have other incentives can we Market more
how do we actually get people back onto
buses
um and what are the levers are available
to uh Council to actually encourage the
use of them
we talked a little bit about the
community connect
um the uh a new contract uh when we're
out to Tinder we will find out what
um
that cost us it's been quite a period of
time since we've been to the market nine
years so
um there's possible that the costs might
be more than we're currently paying
which could be a challenge we've talked
about our e-buses
Drive wage payments is another
challenging position for a community and
that the government has set a range of
expectations through announcements and
the um
past while about what levels they expect
driver pay levels to be
but at the end of the day it is actually
a Council decision about what level you
wish to pay it and that's suggesting
that
um rural bus drivers should be paid 20
28 an hour and urban bus drivers are
being paid 30 an hour whether or not
we choose to do that will be something
that we'll need to have some further
conversations on but that places
quite a significant additional financial
burden on the service
and their budgets
the second part of as I mentioned
briefly is that the Total Mobility has
some I guess that increased subsidy the
lower travel costs we're seeing 40 and
50 increase and the actual cost and to
be fair we don't have um really useful
ways to actually control that level of
spend um how you limit people's saying
in the past we used to have
chuts where you could have six or ten or
Twenty a month um the new electronic
world is a little bit more difficult to
deal with so we have to work on that and
her last piece of work is a national
ticketing system which is a
thing that will replace our root speed
card over the next
three to five years roughly which means
you can travel anywhere in the country
on one standard you don't have to have a
different carton of a cargo different
card in Christchurch different Garden
Wellington yeah
it is you just need to have a credit
card because it's an open loop system so
that's a thing that's coming which will
just give us a little give us something
else to do during the day but that'll be
fine
the things that we probably can't
control and we'll need to do is um the
driver wages there is a huge expectation
in the community
and certainly in unions and Community
about what that means to us
the e-bus changes right well
apologies
the e-bus changes um
it's going to set some certainly set us
up through a tendering process
um there aren't we haven't seen many
small e-buses at the moment and you
can't buy second air buses so
in the demand everybody's got them so
how that really works out
and the Total Mobility is an ongoing
um
currently the government has said it's
an indefinite subsidy so that we'll have
some ongoing impacts on for us
foreign
have a conversation about whether we
have less trips so what I'm saying is do
we need to earlier in the morning or
later in the evening or do we need them
on weekends what are we what are we
where are we heading with that
um the way to make cost savings was we
might put our fears up some further
we'll let's see how our current ones
going but each year you have the
opportunity to at least have that
conversation
but how do we actually make sure we have
more people using it it's the real
challenge
so really moving into a section about
what are the proposals and what are the
options that we actually have to
consider so
things that we
have here and we'll have some options
later on uh the things we've heard in
early discussions are that probably we
would like to have a bus an earlier bus
because at the moment you can catch a
bus to get in to work at eight o'clock
from the suburbs but if you started at
Harbor City and you don't so
and if you don't catch the 520 bus you
have to walk so probably a bit lean and
a bit mean on on that and at the
weekends and on public holidays we have
relatively limited services and there's
conversations that we've heard about are
we providing services to
plus odotara slash airport and around
the CBD so
similar to the previous ones I've um
tried to pull those together and
actually put a bit of a slide up of um
some of the costs that we see and we can
certainly circulate this along with the
other roading one where you can give us
some feedback but
we're suggesting that if you actually
have a bus service that that service is
going to cost us probably three hundred
thousand first year and then 250 000 a
year
um
would be hopeful that we could arrange
we could we get some subsidy on that but
we may not do but that's our best guess
at the moment
if we go into a demand an on-demand
service that we see that we'll need an
extra hundred thousand over above what
we're currently doing
if we have some service to otara and a
limited scope we're saying it's probably
going to cost us 150 000 a year but
we're suggesting that's further out
until we see what need there is
a new bus contract we're anticipating
will cost us more
and we've got some transition costs for
NTS
and our additional trips at the
beginning and end of the day we think
it's going to cost us another hundred
thousand dollars a year
and their Total Mobility Services that's
the sort of our half share of what it's
going to cost us anyway we've got we're
incurring it at the moment
and we're seeing an increased costs
because the cost adjustment type stuff
is growing hugely so we're seeing a BAU
cost going up as well
I'm sorry it's just
pushing buttons
so an air on board of facilities we
think it's going to probably cost us
about eighty thousand dollars a year to
actually provide that on bus service for
audio type stuff that's the order of
cost that we will need to have to have
the audible announcements
um asked a question about that Russell
the previous service how much should
that cost of a similar nature yes sir no
and we just think it has to be a better
technology to deliver than what we
previously did 10 years ago and we've
moved on so far and that technology
there has to be a has to be a solution
and it seems strange that no one else
around the country has actually got a
net based solution that tells you where
you are and where the next stop is it
just seems
we do everything else online or in an
app some kid could I use maps all the
time and it tells me when the next bus
is coming
I'm willing to know where to catch
we have that invercargill as well on
track a bus so you can do that exactly
you can actually look online and see the
little bus telling you when it's going
to be two minutes away but it's actually
when you're on the bus it's the next
stop announcement is the issue that we
face but
you can follow the bar
and it tells you the stops yeah we're
really wanting it so when you're in
there you can have a
hear it where you can listen to it so it
was a submission that we had from
station
and I guess we've been fortunate sorry
to um is that we've had that well in
advance of many many many other places
around the country so that's a pretty
big investment we made for a long time
so
so what we've got here is as our
reasonably
um these are the kpis that we're
currently being measured on so that's
what we still continue to to look for
which about you know passenger boarding
satisfactions and again and the thing
with satisfaction surveys is is actually
Ready To Source your data we do one on
an annual basis we use students um over
December to measure and I know Rhiannon
does some other community ones and
sometimes they they are different
because they test a different Market but
it's about being sure what you're trying
to demonstrate whether you're doing a
good job
um but a lot of them
are about the customers who are using
the service and
how satisfied they are whilst they're
doing it
and that really just shows us where
we're currently trying to seek about a
70 customer survey satisfaction from our
onboard that's where we've been getting
that data we have to capture a whole lot
of this data for a wakatai annually and
that's part of that service
title Mobility is a really difficult one
to measure because we don't actually
necessarily have access to those people
to actually survey them so we just
consider we have an annual meeting
um where all the providers are in this
the sector can come in tell us how we're
doing so I guess that's how we measure
it
but some of our issues are
have been fulfilling these roles but
they're not necessarily air rolls and we
have we haven't been able to fill roles
so how we resource this going forward is
actually a real Challenge and the thing
will be is who's best to manage we have
the delegation from environment salesman
and have had so for probably near 20
years old yes and as it stole
appropriate it could be something to
work through
um we do need to work through our
regional public transport plan which is
the PT version of the long-term plan
and I think some of the regional type
activities in there which will could be
an inclusion of is there a business case
for a fair subsidy to Stuart Island I
know there's
um not been much uptake from wakugoton
that on that basis and we need to
continue to replace bus shuttles
so this is really where we got to with
the um someone to the roading or the
riding one which is really the areas
where we see we've got
um some investment and really Keen at
some stage for Council to give us some
direction about whether the other sorts
of things that we want to include in our
um
activity plan and and our budgets going
forward so that just the things I've
brought forward but happy to try to
explain some of those questions okay it
was that was Trish then Evelyn I've got
a number cheer thank you
just throw something at you so can I
start post for all about the money that
you get in the fare box if you
accelerate the number of children
students traveling on the buses that's
government funded so that will mean more
money in your pockets
correct
um for every trip we get the equivalent
fare funded from the government so if we
could double the number of children
traveling we would get twice as twice as
much money from that area so my next
question is what are you doing to
promote this in the schools
um to be fair we don't have a strong
um communication strategy with with the
schools but it is well used and it's
well known the
um but you the new under
12 free
um we haven't necessarily seen that as a
strong sector um
we also but we also need to be sure that
we've actually got enough capacity to
deliver the service which could be one
of our problems if the if every kid
wants to catch a bus to school we might
need more buses right so I'm looking at
this from education
plus things that I believe
I believe I think
location down here and get them to get
some comms out to the school
um and let them know what's going on we
have a particular problem with refugees
coming to invercargill they tend to live
right down the housing that we can get
quite often it's right down south
invercargill and
um you know these this weather that
we're having is totally difficult for
them and with the school situation the
zoning a child who lives next door to
the taxi
um Center you know thereby pet bastards
so he has to get to be able to get to
Aurora and back and his siblings to
their school so the zoning and
invercargill makes it really difficult
for kids to use the buses and I know
that you're aware of that but I do think
it it's a consideration
um I guess that's part of what the
government's initiative is is to try to
put more if you teach your kids how to
catch buses the more likely as adults to
want to as well so that's probably one
of the deficiencies we have is over the
last generation we haven't caught buses
yeah and their Community too that every
Refugee family has been given by the
council
but the um their cards because and they
are used to using buses so you know if
we could if you could try and perhaps
look at those bus routes particularly
um you know down south is was the
difficult one and anyway just a
consideration
um I've got a few more things so
um Bluff
many of the students who are at Bluff
have difficulty getting into the high
schools or a school there of their
choice because Bluff goes to year seven
eight and then they come to high school
at year nine where they can get a bus
um we don't want to discourage them not
going to the local school but there's no
choice
I understand exactly but I just think
we're just going to be really careful
that we don't overlap the Moe's
responsibilities to and kids as well and
there is a there's a really subtle
balance between us yeah Bluff bus
service that takes
oh you wouldn't want it for the no you
wanted for the children because it does
would create things but I'm thinking
about the community you know if there
was a bus that came into cargo at um
say eight o'clock or something and
returned at 3 30 then it might even be
able to for the community of bluff to be
able to use it or even better if it was
a non-core bus but that's something
you've already talked about have you
thought of hybrid buses
instead of E versus
um I guess the decarbonizing says you
just don't want to have diesel buses so
it doesn't necessarily limit what they
are I'm not sure there's that many
hydrogen buses no no hydrogen but a
hybrid yeah yeah
um
we'll
when we go to Tender we'll be quite
specific about what the rules across the
country have allocated in
we're quite fortunate that the passenger
transport world is now much more
connected because of our B card and Our
Roots work so accessing people who have
already done this is actually really
easy for us I mean what you what you've
got is excellent I mean from what it
used to be it really is but I'm
questioning also whether you need to do
bus shelters when if you have an encore
bus sign they won't need the bus yet
bus routers are a really um thing that
Nathan enjoys mostly
a little joy and I didn't say that and
we have looked quite closely certainly
even changed the roots we
we I mean Nathan spent lots of time
identifying where you can put them and
it's really surprising how many people
um
don't want one NIMBY yep not outside and
I have to say I used to be one of those
I want to use them but they just don't
they're really Keen but they're not in
key they're not they're outside their
house yeah not outside my place so we've
spent quite a bit of time identifying
suitable locations and working really
closely so and but at the same time
we've thought quite a lot about where
they are and the route how many
passengers they are actually getting on
and off so it's not just randomly trying
to find a spot we've thought through
this quite a bit
to further invest yes we'll need new
shelters but we just need to be really
careful that we actually put them in the
right place
um and having better showers that aren't
necessarily defaced and broken and
otherwise actually if they're not an
eyesore but we also
um
didn't for a period of time have seats
in them because we know that if you have
seats in them everybody
does other things other than sitting in
them after the hours so it's trying to
find a balance about what you do in the
right places so in many many bus
shelters overseas have bars you know
just a bar that you can lean against if
you're someone like me who needs to get
the weight off your feet but not a seat
we have done that for a period of time
and meet quite a bit of community
resistance for not having a seat so okay
all right so those are my questions I
mean I love what you're doing but I
think we've got to keep trying to make
that I haven't saw the last one was
surely on a Sunday we could have every
third Sunday or someone kept the buses
coming to town how can some people
access them all at places like that
if we don't have we could do anything
you wish to fund
I know just I just those are my thoughts
oh my God Tom's back
I think Evelyn
so unsurprisingly it's a bus you so I
have one or two things
um but I first of all to follow up with
Trish said
um I heard somebody talk to me not
knowing my connection to council about
the problem that she was having with her
13 year old daughter accessing bus
transporter and from Aurora
which does not involve her having to
walk enormous distances home from
somewhere like South and girls high
because the bus
connections don't go down south
invercargill on the
west side
um so they don't cross over
um I guess they go up from Aurora to
girls high might be the nearest point
for her she's in Collins Street area so
what I would suggest if you've got a
specific weekend yeah because what we
what we often find is that the people
who bring us a problem
um we've looked at it and we actually
get all the roots out and we say well
why don't you do this and they go oh
yeah can you do that because often that
sometimes it's a mix between a school
bus and a Council Bus smart yes knowing
how to do it I wasn't sure what the
answer was and so I raise it if I
couldn't see what the answer was and I
use the buses I'm not quite sure the
solution to a problem but the question I
had within that was how Nimble are we
with the bus routes for say the school
bus routes which I think might vary
um certainly Year from year so if we if
we too close-minded about this is what
we delivered last year so that's what
we're going to deliver next year without
talking to the schools about where their
enrollment patterns are going is that
one of the things we could be doing
smarter or it's a question I don't have
the solution I think it's about trying
to find that balance and um that's one
of the things that we've continued I'm
very regimented because it's on the map
and it's where you're supposed to go
it's a schedule you have to do a whole
lot of other things that support it
others have a little bit more
flexibility with the drivers and I think
sometimes it is actually a little bit
more fluid than we perhaps would always
imagine but the school bus stuff is
about actually understanding where the
kids are and you're 100 right this year
we might have 10 kids in one area and
then next year there's no one so
um but the way the school bus routes
have been designed have generally been
pretty successful because they are full
when we um
solve most of the problems so oh
absolutely but I just it it raised the
question for me how Nimble are we so
thank you
um the other thing is the what you've
mentioned the beginning and the end of
the day now for me to come here and I
generally am a bus user but for me to
come here to be at council at half past
eight that's not possible by bus
unless I get up really really really
early because my bus would come at 25 to
8.
so I think there must be a lot of people
in the same position as me likewise if
um
the chair were to go on a long time it's
the infrastructure meeting and we didn't
leave until five past five I would find
it challenging to actually make the bus
to go home by bus and there must be a
lot of people in that position as well
that pallets are the target
for you to finish before five past five
absolutely
um but but for a lot of working people
are those times actually really working
for them pardon expression
um because we're not really fitting
around people's fixed working times as
opposed to you know if you work start
work at nine you could catch the bus
into town but you probably then don't
finish before five so you might not be
able to make the bus home so that's
that's why we recognize that perhaps
we've been
um we we've tried pretty hard to I guess
find that careful balance between
service and cost and
probably recognize that we probably have
been a bit harsh in some of those
beginning you need and not everybody
travels to the center of City to work
they might travel from the north part of
town to the hospital so they've got to
have two bus trips to get the end or the
other way around so
um it's really easy to run a bus service
so if everybody works at the same place
and lives in the same house
um unfortunately that's not what happens
so it's it is a game of Jigsaw really
puzzles trying to get them together so I
appreciate how things are going I just
as a user I'm mindful what I see as the
limitations but thank you and that's why
we've put up costs to suggest that we do
need to perhaps extend that service
which we'll need to I mean uh thank you
Mr chair Russell I just wanted to um jog
your memory back
um throughout previous workshots this
Council has posed questions like should
we hand back delegation for our public
transport service to
um yes
um and if we do what are the cost
benefit savings from there versus the
negative impact statement from our
community and the needs of our community
so I still um for me that's not
completely been answered yet or threshed
out in robust discussions while we're
considering what council objections for
the future could be alongside of that
we're looking at the way technology is
changing around our country and also the
way that our community needs are
changing in terms of also their work
situations and hours whether they can
work hybrid or not or a lot of community
lives are changing as well which is
impacting on our bus services
what I'm kind of trying to get my head
around is the on-demand services and
concept and then the it that we've got
to have to support that and things like
that so I'm looking at
the cost benefit to us as a service
provider what what would be to improve
and meet
central government policy with
decarbonizing our buses smaller fleets
so that those buses can be full and
what would that cost be just
approximately versus those other costs
or too big a question
come back to me later
too big a question but I guess the first
part is the delegation yes we've still
got that as an ongoing conversation and
I think somewhere I guess we raise it
because it might not necessarily be
the immediate change but it could
actually be that that's a conversation
that we need to contemplate over the
next ltp or something there might be a
time we might still believe that we're
best placed to to deliver the service
because there are lots of councils
across
um the country who are actually wanting
it from the original Council not
actually giving it back so
um that's that's the thing we need to
understand what would be we'd lose or
benefit
I think your question about how do we
actually make our services as Nimble
without investing huge amounts of
capital that lock Us in I suppose it's
the real thing and part of that is the
conversation with our with whomever our
future contractor is because the
viability and their viability is
actually Linked In some in some respect
in there they're not going to want to
buy brand new buses that we say two
years later sorry we don't want them
anymore because we'll pay we'll pay the
privilege of that but at the same time
if they've seen huge benefits elsewhere
across the country where they've seen
something similar that's worked really
efficiently we'll also challenge them to
bring that concept to us and we know
that on-demand buses work better for
some things but not for others so
scheduled bus service is still the most
cost effective way to do it the
on-demand Services typically cost more
per trip
but they perhaps give you a little more
flexibility for location and we've got
chunks where we um
you've got to work at walk the 500
meters to a bus and that's that's the
reality of you can't hit everybody can't
be lucky enough to have a bus stop and
bus Shadow outside the house that's
right we'll wind that up now thanks very
much that's right on time five two thank
you Nathan thank you Russell are you
staying for the next one
you are discharged now
right next one is the impact the last
one today was regulatory services
and Jonathan welcome
and Jillian
um thank you for seeing us short notice
transport stuff has control of
PowerPoint
okay um so we're going to cover
um what we refer to as one of the more
exciting parts of the um organization
regulatory Services activity
um so the regulatory Services activity
is responsible for the delivery of the
key legislative requirements relating to
building planning food alcohol
environmental health parking compliance
Animal Control environmental health and
litter it is hard to think of anybody in
the community that isn't touched by one
of the activities that we're responsible
for either drawing on the service or if
they're somewhat naughty they may find
us doorstep
yeah
so actually just to get back to that so
we've got we've got three essentially
we've got three teams in the group at
the moment which is building and
planning
um which I've been covering previously
uh Jillian covers Environmental Services
we also have property records
um I'll be covering them as well at the
moment
let's get through this so our current
budget I can barely make it out without
my glasses
so essentially we've got we've got about
uh somewhere in the region of 37 to 38
ftes we do also in building and planning
we make use of contractors
to carry out some of the functions in
particular building consent processing
we tend not to draw on the services of
Consultants so much and Consultants
would typically work in the policy space
we have used them
we're trying to limit our use of them
and try and grow some of the capability
in-house
so
so in terms of maintaining levels of
service for Environmental Services uh
one of the challenges over the next ltp
is going to be ensuring that we have
cost recovery of our services set at the
creek levels
we've got fees that that we're able to
set ourselves such as our these four
food act then we have other fees that
are set by legislation such as alcohol
and also parking infringements
in terms of our food verification and
alcohol we also need to ensure that we
have our cost recovery set at 100 for
where we're providing Services into
other councils we do that for clutha and
Gore where we include that we provide
food act environmental health and
Alcohol Services in clutha we provide
them with just the food X services
foreign
services that we have that we also need
to ensure that we've got our cost
recovery correct is uh the shed service
Arrangement that we have with Southland
district council at our Animal Care
Facility
where they have a long-term license for
five kennels at the ACF
that is charged out on a 5 of 28
cost for the operating cost for the year
annually and then they pay uh the daily
rate for whenever they have dogs in the
facility
one of the other key areas that we've
got around parking that we need to
consider going forward is nationally
there is a review of infringement fees
that has been going on for the past 18
odd months we have no confirmed timeline
or fee structure for this year but it
will likely be coming in in the next
three years
the phase infringement fees are likely
to rise significantly as you've got
areas such as the big cities around
Auckland Wellington and that we're
currently
the infringement fees are
much cheaper than parking
so we're likely to see significant
increases there
we're not sure what that will do to our
infringement income in invercargill if
that would see a significant increase
assuming that we would have the same
levels of infringements or if we're
likely to see people more inclined to
actually pay for their parking or ensure
that they're not receiving infringements
other things that we've got to consider
around levels of service is
um we're seeing more and more a backdrop
of increasing aggression in the
community particularly with some of our
roles such as parking officers
Animal Control
in the animal control space we're
wanting to have a significant focus on
decreasing the number of unregistered
dogs in the district
so there's there's two levels of that
there there's there's the unregistered
dogs that we know about because they've
been registered in the past and they're
not currently registered and then
there's the unregistered population that
we don't know about so a lot of work
um covering both of those areas
foreign
we're also looking to ensure that we're
using education as much as possible
around compliance education and
assisting people to comply being more
cost effective than enforcement or
directed enforcement for compliance
Jonathan so so yeah I think on the whole
it's um regulatory uh
we feel that we're providing a service
to the community that meets the
expectations of the community
I often say that good regulatory
function tends to be fairly silent you
only notice it when it's missing
I'm sorry if we if we look at Planning
and Building uh and also probably
records so Jillian touched on this uh in
in general the expectation is that the
user pays where you're drawing on a
service from invercargill city council
you should pay the costs of it
um the current ltp we have
um
it allows a certain amount of
flexibility between what we what we're
recovering from cost of the service but
also what we're being rated for and it's
marginal so it actually runs between 10
and 50.
one of the challenges we have is that
some some of the functions that we carry
out are quite easily cost recoverable
cost of a building consent or resource
consent for example
um other thing other activities we have
to undertake that the community expects
is going to take on quite say cost
recoverable for example
um abandoned vehicles people that dump
them on the beach and set fire to them
that that can impose significant costs
on us I think it's fair to say that
previously ICC hasn't had a real
compliance Focus
uh particularly with building and it has
been quite it's been quite a challenge
over the last three years to bring that
up to see where it actually needs to be
we have a few Legacy issues and
obviously the longer you leave them the
harder it tends to be
um some some of the work
is probably overdue by a decade we'd had
good fortune in that many of you has led
to members will be aware that we often
report on our interactions with
International accreditation New Zealand
irons who created us for both building
but also environmental health with
building they tend to have quite a
narrow Focus which is on the issue of
building consents where compliance
matters are concerned
there probably wasn't so much of an
incentive to perform in that area
because it wasn't frankly reviewed that
changed in 2020 and they started
reviewing that invercargill city council
we're subject we were one of the first
up to be reviewed and there were a few
elements
um where we had quite a bit of work to
do around fencing swimming pools
implying schedules updating the
compliance schedules and also building
warrant of Fitness audits
we've been on a three-year project to
reduce that to something that's
manageable we've had to regularly report
to envy and I'm really pleased to say
that we've reached the point now where
we have that under control but it has
come at a cost
and I think what has come out of this is
that that cost will now be ongoing
um
compliance isn't just something that you
can suddenly bring up today and then put
away again what you tend to find with
compliance is that it nudges better
behaviors from the community
I mean it's it's a little like housework
a little and often tends to be the
cheaper option uh
typically where you're taking a
reasonable line and helping people and
encouraging them to uh
perform as good citizens it tends to
work out easier for us where we let it
go the costs of then carrying out
enforcement action can be quite
expensive
um as with any service the cost of
maintaining existing service levels
increases year on year prices very
rarely go down
and I don't think anyone would suggest
that we would want to
move reduce our level of service here
either
um
there are some interlinked elements to
it the cost of consents
whether they be resource consensual
people you can sense it does have it
have implications for projects
so that also links to the greater than
the cargo
to refer to my earlier point on
compliance monitoring compliance and
enforcement isn't it's not largely cost
recoverable
we're required to take the action and we
need to get those better behaviors it it
can be counterproductive where we're
going in with a stick as our first
method in imposing high costs on people
to comply when that money arguably may
be better used in
achieving a level of compliance first
step
I think a really good example here is um
the tragedy of the loafers Lodge fire
um
we had the satisfaction as a council of
knowing that we had actually undertaken
our building warrant and fitness
activities properly and that we had
actually
already made an assessment of those type
of buildings and we were working with
building owners to get better outcomes
from it
one of the other one of the other issues
and this was largely in an 11th Hour
part is that with um
with planning in particular uh it looks
as though the RMA reform is starting to
ratchet up it's last week the select
committee have indicated that they're
likely to recommend that both the new
pieces of legislation that we previously
talked about in workshops are enacted
I have every reason to believe they'll
be enacted before the election
um as to when they'll come into Force
that's a different matter but it's
likely to
change the direction the council has to
move in regard to policy
and as we've already
talked about a previous Workshop there's
a need to do some policy work on our
current District plan there is a concern
that it's likely we'll be working on
both the new RMA reform as well as our
current District plan
potentially the value of working on the
current District plan to change and put
in some plan changes that will enable
development and housing it's not an
opportunity I imagine that the cancer
would wish to let slide on
that has implications for the costs of
providing
regulatory function
challenge here is going to be it's very
difficult I think what those costs are
likely to be
we could potentially have to do more
work in in the policy area
um looking at property records one of
the issues we have there is that
currently the process is very manual and
time consuming we're still uh we still
haven't achieved 50 of property record
digitization
we tend to fail the large number of
inquiries from the community in regard
to property file requests and we're
required to make reasonable access so we
tend to have to do a lot of manual
handling the digitization project is set
to finish in April next year
one of the key pieces of work that we
want to look at moving forward from that
is the potential to put the information
online and for those of you that are
familiar with Queenstown they have the
edoc system
potentially a lot of cost Savings in
there where people can look up their own
property records it's not without
privacy issues
um indications are it won't be
effortless to implement but it certainly
has a potential I'd say within the next
two or three years to assist us in the
meantime and we're
probably having to use around about two
ftes per week
um just to deal with property file
requests and move the information around
there's also a need to look at some of
the processes that property records are
responsible for in particular land
information memorandums limbs they just
literally required to do those we we're
undertaking some workers to just how
much information we have to capture uh
traditionally it was quite a brief
overview central government have
provided direction that they expect us
to apply far more diligence right
eating Limbs and
actually making sure that we are
providing the information and that we're
going into a reasonable amount of depth
that does carry a fair amount of
liability for the council
so um and in terms of options
um
an increase in funding is required to
maintain current Service delivery due to
the increased cost of service delivery
year on year
um an increase in funding will be
required for compliance activities in
order to avoid oppose imposing
unreasonable costs on those who do
comply
when we were looking at setting the fees
it was becoming clear that people who
were obtaining building consents were
starting to unreasonably bear the burden
of the cost of service delivery
probably reasonable to say that people
would anticipate that with a user pays
system that then becomes inequitable
and and again just to return to the the
theme of we now meet our obligations as
a territorial Authority
um an increase in funding is going to be
required to ensure that we maintain
Meeting those obligations
in response to requests from elected
members regarding potential to improve
the appearance of non-heritage buildings
in the CBD there is a paper coming to
cancel I think on the 25th of July
outlining some options
uh having discussed the matter with
other councils they've strongly
recommended incentivizing where possible
they've found that the compliance stick
doesn't work so well arguably the the
building X not the best piece of
legislation to deal with the appearance
of buildings it deals with the safest
buildings so an increase in funding may
be required depending on which way the
council wants to go in that direction
um and also the the fourth bullet point
is regarding the RMA reform
um
there's likely to be some quite serious
cost implications for us for the
regional spatial strategy
um
currently there is a joint initiative
between councils to work on a regional
spatial plan at the moment which is in
process we're expecting a report
um actually this month that should be
coming up to council
to explain the progress that we've made
so far with the RMA reform uh the
regional spatial work becomes mandated
indications are that they'll send
councils in what they um entrances uh
obviously it's
we're not going to be in the first
tranche it would seem they've already
set the councils that they're going to
work on that with already but it could
be we could be directed to go in the
second tranche which I would suggest
would be somewhere within two to three
years
um as I said that could then lead us
into the unfortunate position of having
to work on our district plan to get some
plan changes at the same time as having
to work on Regional spatial work which
will
we're currently not geared up for it
with the planning team it will impose it
will enable to impose in additional
costs
opportunities for cost Savings in the
Environmental Services area under an
animal control later this year we're
going to start engaging with the
community regarding Mo for a tag for
life
for the dog registration process while
this won't
um result in any cost Savings in the
first year and subsequent subsequent
years at will
um at the same time we will also look to
moving registration process to email as
much as possible removing one of the
biggest
expenditures from the dog registration
process which is postage
uh
as we continue to ensure that we have a
high number of uh
dogs registered in the community this
will also have an impact on the the fees
for dogs for dog registration
in terms of environmental health there
are limited opportunities to reduce the
cost of service
and as I mentioned previously the focus
will be ensuring on the fact that we've
got accurate cost recovery and 100 cost
recovery for services provided to other
councils
um and within parking compliance again
our fees are set by legislation
so limited opportunities for cost
recovery across the service
within the animal control area as well
we'll be we've got some planned projects
and prioritizing other projects around
the Animal Welfare code and health and
safety that will reduce our Reserve over
time
sorry
yeah so um taken as a whole with
regulatory uh the opportunities for cost
savings are few and far between unless
we we look at uh reducing Service uh
some of the some of the items that we
have looked at a renewed focus on cost
recovery
um also a systems review based on lean
principles so
ensuring that we're not putting too many
steps in the process we have undertaken
some work with the teams already
if you take the position that when
someone applies to us for a resource
consent or a building consent there are
parts of the process that add value for
them there are also Parts a process that
don't and we need to just be aware that
whilst we may consider some of those
parts of approaches or required value
for us at the regulator
we can sometimes get into a position
where there are also parts of the
process of just aren't adding value for
either party and so we're starting to
review those systems of asking ourselves
a bit of faster way of delivering uh
service it's uh it's in its infancy
um and it's not a Silver Bullet by any
means it does take time to work through
these things it has to move in line with
some of the other work that the
organizations do in business enhancement
program Etc
uh we're also looking at the cost to
current systems in comparison with
others
um
so when I uh first started here taking
on the piece of building consent
processing software
um it's time to ask ourselves if that's
the most effective way if there's a
cheaper way other councils actually have
their own editable forms they've created
that is submitted via report or
um and that they can review and that is
arguably a cheaper system so we're
starting to work with other councils to
see if they've got better ways of doing
it
so right are we finished with the slides
um and obviously fourth four fourth
point is create efficiency I think we've
got three more slides to go through okay
we'll just we'll go to the end of the
slide
so proposals for new or lifted level of
service you want to cover your one uh
the focus and environmental services
um will be on ensuring our shared
services enhancing our shared services
contracts with our territory authorities
we'll be looking to ensure that all of
our services are online for our
application processes across all of our
areas and another area that is possible
to look at is using CCTV is a tool for
parking enforcement
that does remove an element of your
education Focus
if you if you move to doing something
like that
okay um and so we're Planning and
Building obviously we touched on policy
work RMA reforms going to put more of a
lens on that for us along with the
district plan review
and we're bringing the paper on an
initiative to promote improved
appearance of non-heritage buildings in
the city center with property records
I've already talked on the potential for
online access there's also the
introduction or fair to say the
reintroduction of project information
memorandums pims
typically if you apply for a building
consent as part of that you can apply
for a project information memorandum
that will then mean that checks are
carried out to ensure that
um your project is feasible but it's
going to meet
um the requirements of the district plan
it is entirely possible if you don't
obtain a Pim to actually uplift the
building consent that you simply can't
build under the district plan
um we undertake those checks to ensure
that that's not going to happen but
arguably we need to make sure that
people are uplifting pims because those
checks need to be paid for and the
project information memorandum is a
proper platform to do it on
foreign
has already stated overall there's
little to no scope reducing service
levels below the current state without
increasing risk and liability to the
cancer
uh council could consider if they wish
to review their risk appetite in regard
to undertaking regularly regulatory
functions
these are the options uh in regard to
um
improving the appearance of buildings in
the CBD option one will be the
regulatory enforcement approach
to attempt to use the building act
option two will be an enabling approach
um
option three is an incentive fund
for is no additional action so those
will be brought up to cancel on the 25th
of July
in terms of measuring performance we
have legislative kpis
uh
building resource consents food and
alcohol applications it's 100 within the
statutory time frames which are
typically 20 working days
um also we promote incentives to owners
of Heritage buildings especially when
they undertake earthquake strengthening
so we have the heritage
program that has been highly successful
to date
and then also we have the number of land
information memorandums issued within 10
working days so we're not proposing any
additional kpis other than the
legislative ones
that's it
right
thank you uh questions funny
don't registration all that it's great
you said is there more work needed to be
done around building and planning around
building seats and or processes there's
always there's always more work needed
um we have to keep up with the times uh
invercargill city council quite
revolutionary when they introduced video
inspections and that's been quite a game
changer for the industry there's always
the potential one of the challenges
though is that people tend to work on a
variety of media and platforms
um some people are very good at
electronic stuff other people just deal
in paper and we are legally required to
provide all those Avenues it can be
quite challenging okay it's not often
but occasionally we do have to accept
large paper applications over the
counter
real
um thank you for your in-depth um scope
there I found it quite interesting I
just wanted to touch on a couple of
things
um under the animal control area
um I realized that we have a I don't
know what you call it good dog behavior
subsidy
um you talked about you know of the
animals that have been visited but not
currently registered
um is it something that in forward
thinking that the council could do an
amnesty weekend to allow people to bring
their dogs in to get inspected to get
chip to get whatever we want we
partnership up with our community
businesses to allow that enablement to
happen so it takes away the fair process
of oh my God my dog's not reached it I
owe so much money let me get slipped on
the hands how about we take that barrier
away from them as part of our well-being
of our community include their dogs
inside of that too other thing is a tag
for life concept of the of the animals
what happens when the animal dies Beyond
its lifespan will people be expected to
get a reimbursement for the scope of the
life that they didn't live out to I mean
I can see some operational issues within
that
um within that that policy I mean I
think it's good but it's like
maybe a little bit of consideration it
just means you don't have to change tax
every year to your dog every year it
would be but then yeah but then if
you're going to do like a tech for life
and they go oh well our dog got killed
last week it's not the life so can we
get some reimbursement back on that tag
change the cost of registration every
year I know I'm gonna pay registration I
realize that I realize that you do now
get a reimbursement don't shoot your dog
there is under the actor um it's a it's
a pro rata and it's uh based on uh when
you notify us that your dog has died not
right on that same question though those
tags don't last the other thing the live
that's the only thing so what about
getting new ones and things yeah you
would we would have to have the ability
to be able to have replacement tags
um there's a number of council sort of
done this already there was a number
that started this year with this year's
registration a number last year and the
year before so
we can do a lot of learning from what
other councils have have gone through
already like their pain points from when
they've done it right okay that sounds
good and my only other commentary was on
the um comment that you made about the
CCTV being used as a parking
infringement tool
um and I just needed some clarification
on that because when we talked about the
CCTV coverage and our investment and
that it was more for like Community
safety safety of our businesses and now
we're looking at opening it up more to
signing people for a parking
infringement I'm kind of thinking did we
consult and put it out there on that
basis as well yeah but nobody nobody
gets a ticket for doing something right
rare I realized that Darren you're only
good it's actually looking at the
regulatory areas of what the tools about
I think I think when it comes to the
CCTV and I can talk about this the the
actual system when it goes in will have
a lot of features and whether you use
them or not I mean number plate
recognition is one and that'll be
definitely used for Traffic Control
whether that's used for parkings another
thing the other thing is that these new
systems have facial recognition and that
of course there's a privacy act thing
and and they also have features like if
you read cap blue jacket and whatever
you can follow that you could literally
track those features
are embedded but whether you use them or
not is up to another it's up to policy
and stuff like that so I think having
the tool available for parking is a good
thing to have effort if it if it's
suitable yeah
so oh we have to go in two minutes so
Evelyn
um just a clarification
um if you microtip your dog the vet does
that and it's registered on a register
um
do we get notified about this or is that
one of the discussions we should be
having because that would mean we would
know the existence of dogs that we
perhaps currently don't know about on
the other hand when Vex then put a dog
to sleep they would
to say that it would be able to notify
that that is a dog out of the system I'm
just trying to think about what happens
now who benefits from the from the
microchipping
what information is collected to whom is
it given and where do we fit in that in
terms of environmental control the Dog
Control Act and all those sorts of
things and how can we make it all those
pieces of legislation work
together to make the costs cheaper for
um a dog owner but also make our work a
little bit easier
it's currently the responsibility of the
dog owner to ensure that they provide us
with microchip but we do work with vets
um to if they don't know what it is but
they do know who their vet is we will
talk to them
um
and in terms of when your dog is passed
again it's the responsibility of you as
the owner to pass that information onto
us
and there is a refund available
the information when it comes to council
goes into our Council systems and also
onto the national dog database you can
also choose to pay a fee to have your
micro your microchip number for your cat
or dog sorry
um but it does do cats as well onto the
New Zealand Companion Animal register uh
but we tend to deal we deal with our
registers in the MDD the huge Advantage
is that if you've got your your animal
microchipped then if it if it gets out
even if you're the best owner in the
world and it manages to sneak out
somehow then we can scan your dog we can
get it home pretty quickly
so let's see here
I was surprised that I think I was the
first one to register my job on the new
system because it actually didn't allow
much job payment but we didn't catch up
on that but in saying that you have to
load all that information but the other
thing I just want to build on what we
said around the chipping because then we
do seeks your dog it's cheaper
I mean
I think that's a choice then so whether
you're dissection of or don't dissect
your dog but why are we charging more if
you choose not to just extra dog
to encourage people to desex them
whether it's a cost to people as well
I think yeah look we need to iron this
up now but but as chair I'll just before
I hand over to Rhiannon just a couple of
my comments being a a dog owner
um I feel tags for a start there's two
types of tags is the disc that's got a
re-wire anything they don't last long if
you get the other one and manage to put
it on it'll never come off so that's
fantastic that the one you've got to
push through and punch and click as far
as desexing goes
um
problem dogs are the ones that are still
in Tech unfortunately as far as
aggression goes to other dogs and
everything so I am a true believer that
there is uh there should be a discount
for behavior of the D6 dogs so that's
why that and I believe also that our dog
fees are extremely cheap if we can pay
for our entire service at 51 for uh a
dog that's got all the good behavior and
everything then that's amazing I just
looked at Palmerston North the cheapest
you can pay there is ninety two dollars
for everything so if we can fund our
entire department on that we're doing
real good
um thank you
I'd like to spend a bit more actually
maybe on barking dogs
anytime yeah no that's okay so we're
gonna wind that up before we close down
Rhiannon is going to say a couple of
words
um so thank you everyone
um we will come out with a document
which will include all the options that
the managers have presented today
through this workshop and if you can
respond and give an indication of the
areas that are priorities for you that
will help the managers in bringing
forward the final plans and options for
decision by Council you've heard a lot
today I know so I think that's a good
way of doing it in terms of you'll have
a document you can go through and in at
a time that's convenient and then we'll
do the same after the next two workshops
as well
um
that's it yep so thanks everyone we've
now very soon uh got a presentation on
the 1225 is that right yeah yeah